here now lara logan host uh lara logan
has no agenda on fox nation larry the
situation at the airport just getting
worse mass chaos confusion you've got
some sources on the ground there
families that are desperate to get out
of there what are you
hearing well jesse i was on the phone
pretty much all through the night last
night with um
many families on the ground a number of
them who worked with me at 60 minutes
for 20 years and that's why i'm helping
them get out because they've been
threatened and they're targets and it
was really the most um
it was one of the most distressing
things i've ever experienced because why
you know when the bombs went off they
were telling me that kids are screaming
most of the pictures that you've seen
across social media today of all the
people who are lying dead and the
wounded those were taken by the brother
of our 60 minutes afghan producer and um
you know for joe biden to stand up there
on the day that all of these afghans
have been killed and to pretend
that this is some kind of tragedy and he
cares about the death of american
soldiers if you cared about it why did
you do it why did you create this
situation and why aren't you doing
anything to change it you know going to
the taliban and asking them let's can we
stop pretending now that the taliban are
not terrorists can we stop pretending
that the haqqani network is not the
number two the leader of the haqqani
network the afghan al-qaeda is the
deputy commander of the taliban so let's
stop pretending that the taliban are not
isis you know what the afghans will tell
you that the acting president now um
who's an old friend of mine i've
interviewed him many times on 60 minutes
he said to me when we interrogate these
people when we get them on the
battlefield you know what we find out
today they're isis two weeks ago they
were taliban and two years ago they were
al-qaeda or something like that you know
so they're not fooling anybody except
you know unfortunately
the americans they're fooling joe biden
it's a slippery group of tribesmen and
cells and terror networks they change
their appearance they change their name
they change sides constantly you know
they're all corrupt and the fact that
joe didn't see the afghan army
collapsing like this who is he kidding
me i've never been over there you go
online you look at a video have you ever
seen the jumping jacks these guys were
doing they did frontline reporting these
guys couldn't even tell time they were
all smoking dope
they didn't do it they couldn't put
their helmet on straight
and then you expected them to hold the
taliban advance
it's no wonder they got bribed and they
went back to the fields
no you know what jesse i have to tell
you a couple things first of all it
didn't collapse in 11 days no it
collapsed strategic territory
right they you know and also
don't forget the afghan commandos their
special forces that has been the
backbone of the u.s effort in
afghanistan they have borne the brunt of
most of the operational tempo these guys
are you know they are among the best of
the very best with any military in the
world you don't see much from them but
sometimes they're indistinguishable from
americans in some when you do see them
on the battlefield because they've done
thousands of operations but these are
highly specialized
forces that rely on mobility so when you
take away the air force when you take
away the air support what do you do you
could have a group of delta operators
and if they're outnumbered and they're
out of ammo and they're surrounded by
their enemy you know what's going to
happen the same thing that happened to
many of these guys and they were
executed when they surrendered but you
know what happened to thousands more of
them jesse they fought their way from
kandahar in the south and across the
mountains to the panchayat valley where
they went with their equipment some of
them died along the way and they are
fighting still now today so when the
president of the united states says that
he is lying and he is literally taking
the blood of our afghan allies do you
know what's happening on the ground now
jesse do you know that americans decent
good americans who served alongside
these people have said we will not be
part of this betrayal that is drenched
in the blood of afghans and now in the
blood of u.s marines as well and they're
going out on their own this government
is lying about everything i know people
in the evacuations today who said that
there's not even close to the 7 000
number that they said went out that that
is absolutely false that they didn't
have the equipment in place for that
there weren't even a number of people
allowed in we all know all of us are up
all night that's why my voice is crazy
we all know that they've been turning
away u.s citizens do you know that there
are american children born in this
country whose parents are not being
allowed to get on planes with them
because they have green cards and they
can't hide it because we've seen yes
inside of planes taking off there's like
five guys in there planes empty and i
don't want to hear any more numbers and
how successful this airlift is it's a
scramble to the gates to get out because
you booted it everybody can see it you
don't pull air support ground support
before you pull out i mean i'm not
patting but anybody knows that larry i
gotta run thank you so much for your
reportage
it's excellent we appreciate it
thanks jesse hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else